China and Iran signed a Comprehensive
Strategic Partnership in March 2021,
strengthening economic and security
cooperation between the two countries.
According to media reports, the
investment amount is $400 billion USD
across 25 years, but the chinese government has
yet to confirm this number.
Here's why: China's Ministry of Commerce
has the cumulative stock of Chinese
investment in Iran at barely over $3 billion
at the end of 2019. The China Global Investment Tracker
has total chinese investment in Iran at
$4.7 billion from 2005 to 2020.
Chinese companies have promised Iran
large projects in the past. For example,
China National Petroleum Corporation's
contract to develop phase 11 of the South Pars Gas Field
failed because of project delays and US sanctions.
The tracker pegs the dollar value of
failed Chinese projects in Iran at $25.9 billion,
dwarfing realized spending. All of this casts doubt on large investment promises in the partnership.
Do you think the China–Iran partnership
will be successful?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.